[Music]
hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're gonna be going
over one of the most popular openings in
the game the roy lopez and actually
really liked using the roy lopez
especially against weaker opponents if
you're playing a gambit opening or kind
of a unorthodoxed opening there's always
a lot of unknown variables that can
sneak up and bite you but with the roy
lopez it's pretty much a straightforward
game and the high rated player should
win there's not a lot of craziness that
goes on or unexpected moves that you
probably haven't seen before so we're
gonna go ahead and get into it and kind
of go over some of the key concepts to
keep in mind when you do play the roy
lopez and hopefully this will help so
the war Lopez starts out pawn to e4
black responds pawn to e5 y develops his
knight Knight to f3 black responds
Knight to c6 and then Bishop pins down
the knight on the third move with Bishop
to b5 now right away you can see on
white second move white is bringing his
knight into the game attacking this pawn
on the e5 square trying to challenge the
center of black
black develops his knife adding a
defense to this pawn and so why it's
gonna go ahead and come in and pin this
knight anytime that black moves this
pawn which he eventually will to gain
sooner control with his pawn his nights
gonna be pinned down to his King he
can't move his knight because his King
would be in check so this right here is
the Roy Lopez now there are many many
many variations of the boiler PES as far
as what black can do how white can
respond we're gonna get into some of the
main lines just so you know something
two key concepts the first most popular
line that you will see is black
responding a six and he'll do this for a
couple reasons the main reason he's
trying to alleviate this pin on the
black knight y can do two things and
we're gonna kind of go over his two
options here obviously one he can take
this knight and the second thing is he
can go ahead and retreat and wait for a
better opportunity now in the exchange
variation which we'll look at right now
which is bishops takes knight on c6
basically blacks going to respond pawn
takes d6 and black has a
double pawn right here and that's very
key to look at because later on down the
road you always want to find a weakness
that your opponent has and try to
exploit it in this case anytime you can
get pawn stacked on top of each other
that is that is not good for blacks so
you're definitely gonna want to exploit
that but at the same time you want to
figure out what you gave up and why gave
up his LightSquared Bishop and for any
of you have watched other my videos know
that the light-square bishop is probably
White's best minor piece the minor
pieces being the Knights and the bishops
only because it takes a stab at this
very crucial f7 square and f7 is the
weakest point in Black's defense mostly
because when he castles his King will be
on g8 and the f7 square if pinned down
by the light square Bishop cannot move
and you can get some very tactical Forks
in here pinning down this piece so that
is something to keep in mind when you
play the exchange variation that yes you
do give black a double pawn but at the
same time you're giving up your most
powerful minor piece so if you are very
good at exploiting a weakness and you
feel that you can play without your
permission then go ahead use the
exchange variation it is still very good
for white you just need to keep that in
mind
black does have good compensation as far
as he still has both his bishops which
is pretty lethal especially in the
opening game in an open game where
there's not a lot of cluster in the
middle which can you know it's still up
in the air as far as if this is going to
be an open game with not a lot of pawns
or a close game with
not a lot of opening for the bishop to
move we're gonna go over a different
move if you really like your Bishop pair
and don't want to sacrifice at the
beginning I myself played this variation
just because I really like to keep my
light square bishop just because of the
the possibilities that he has especially
against this weakness of the f7 square
so he has two options obviously Bishop
can come to c4 or he can come to a4 and
it's recommended just that the bishop
comes down to a4 for two reasons
the first one is just to obviously get
out of the way of the attack from the
black palm but you always want to keep
going with the attack that you have and
why it has this pin right here on the
Black Knight so to get it right off the
off the pin right away it's kind of
self-defeating if we were gonna do that
we should have moved our Bishop to c4 in
the first place but we did not and from
here a lot of times blacks just going to
respond pawn to b5 especially if he
moved a six
he eventually if not on this next movie
it's gonna move pawn to b5 and then from
here you're simply going to move Bishop
to b3 and as you see this is a nice
little outlet we are eyeing down the f7
square if anytime black tries to promote
his pawns down here and try to bring the
force the bishop off this square white
at any time has a nice little nifty
maneuver that he can just move his pawn
to a3 and he can easily have a nice
little outpost for his LightSquared
Bishop on a2 and he can just I down this
f7 square the entire game and then have
just constant pressure
on the kingside of black from here
you'll normally see black develop either
one of two ways he's eventually gonna
bring his Bishop to e7 and he's
eventually going to bring his knight to
f6 we'll go ahead and look at f6 even
though both of them will eventually
happen now as you can see this knight is
eyeing down this efore pawn of white but
we're going to go ahead and castle in
this situation because if black tries to
capture here we can always bring our
rook we can always bring our queen into
the mix and after he moves his knight
for safety we can go ahead and capture
with our knight here and if he then
recaptures with his knight we can then
take with either our queen or rook and
the King will be in check so very good
situation for us and this right here is
one of the most common opening looks
that you'll see from the roy lopez if
you're playing the non exchange
variation if you're playing the exchange
variation obviously the knight and the
bishop will not be here and you'll have
double pawns on the c file but from this
variation it's very straightforward
black's going to continue with eise evan
he's going to castle white is going to
develop eventually there's going to be
an attack on the
black kingside depending on where black
moves white can develop and there's not
again I'll said there's not a lot of
trickeration in this it's pretty
straightforward it's fine
tactics are gonna win this game
sometimes it can be somewhat boring as
you can see there hasn't been one piece
that's been captured so far but if you
rule enjoy chess and really enjoy out
thinking your opponent on every move
this is a very good opening so hope this
was helpful hope you learned a lot from
the roy lopez there's many variations
that we're actually going to get into in
some of the later videos but please
subscribe you can find out when the new
videos come out I have quite a few
videos coming out in the near future so
check out the website it's going to be
actually launching at the end of this
week March 20th so hope you all enjoyed
and see you next video